I am a cloud engineer here at Google and
being privileged to be working with
James and Vinnie here at Colgate for the
past for the past year I also want to
acknowledge Chris who's in the audience
who's our Tam who's been doing a lot of
the work with us as well and today we're
here to talk about migration to Google
cloud platform that we've done with
Colgate over the last year we as for
those of you that were at the keynote
this morning micro the CIO of Colgate
talked about a successful implementation
of sa P Hybris on GCP installation from
scratch which showed the agility of GCP
to Colgate and I'm excited to say that
this weekend we completed a migration of
another s ap Hybris to GCP that is live
up and running which is another
ecommerce site all exciting it's been a
lot of work and exciting and James and
Vinnie are here to talk to you and tell
you about their experiences one comment
though in some of the sessions I know
you we there was a Dory were you able to
ask questions for various reasons we
decided not to have a Dory but we are
here to stay after the presentation and
answer any questions that you have and
so we'd love to share our migration
experiences with you so good afternoon
everyone and welcome to our session over
the next few minutes Vinnie and I will
take us through and that would be nice
thanks Vinnie Vinnie and I will take us
we'll take you through how we're gaining
agility with with by utilizing GCP so as
part of the agenda we'll go a quick
overview of who Colgate is as a company
we'll talk about that ecommerce
implementation that Naomi mentioned and
we'll also talk about how we're
leveraging
Google cloud platform to extend our data
center and gain agility so Colgate
Palmolive is a 200 plus year old company
and with approximately 34,000 Colgate
people worldwide our products are sold
in over 200 crunch
and we sell our products in four key
categories we have our oral care pet
nutrition home care and personal care
lines and as you can see we have some of
the most world recognizable brands and
depending on where you are from in the
world some may be more recognizable than
others so let's quickly go through how
we built that new e-commerce e-commerce
site and for Colgate in a Google cloud
platform so we we had a challenge from
the business it was a challenge to
implement an e-commerce solution and an
S AP ecommerce site solution from start
to pilot in three months so we reviewed
our on-premise environment and found
that we didn't have the hardware
on-premise to support this
implementation and we also knew that the
hardware procurement cycle could take up
to two months just itself on Prem so we
had to be we also didn't know if it was
going to be a small medium or large
platform so that was what that meant we
had to find somewhere that was scalable
so GCP was the perfect fit so as part of
that we also had to integrate with our
as part of moving that application or
building that application in Google we
had to integrate with our current
on-premise environment so we had to lay
a foundation and part of that was
building the network connectivity using
using Google services such as cloud VPN
and cloud VPC we were able to build that
Network which gave us which allowed us
to build the application in Google and
and provide access to the storage and
images to run that application as well
as other back-end s ap applications what
was good it was that foundation was
built within a week and we were also
leveraging that foundation as part of
any new implementation in Google going
forward so it was one-stop shopping
so as a result after we built the
foundation we were able to stand up this
whole environment in one day by being
agile with by standing up this
environment we provided this environment
to our to our application teams and then
they were able to produce to install the
application and produce testing cycles
within a few days after that so as a
result our IT organization was able to
meet our business goals and we provided
a future roadmap for delivering rapid
solutions to the business so future
state we'd like to be able to beyond be
even more agile by using third-party
application third-party providers such
as terraform to leverage infrastructure
as a code and be more agile going
forward so let me hand you over to
Vinnie who's going to take you over
through our migration project so again
my name is Vincent Richie I am the lead
cloud engineer at Colgate Palmolive and
today we're going to go over some of the
foundational elements we had to put in
place prior to migrating to GCP so the
scope of the project was simple on paper
we had to migrate a workload of 1,200
Windows machines and stay within the
lift and shift migration strategy we
wanted to avoid any rear connecting or
Reap platforming as anywhere possible
that way we could keep our targeted
goals in place early on we partnered
with Google's professional services
organization they helped us move along
that journey to migrate to GCP we do
this in a couple different ways so what
we did in the beginning is we set up a
bunch of in-depth of workshops with our
on-premise support teams that gave us
the ability to identify how Colgate
operates on a day to day from their
Google was able to produce a technical
design document and that became our
true roadmap or our blueprint going
forward on how we're actually going to
migrate to GCP now within that TDD it
was broken up into sections of the
project and that those sections were
called work streams we're gonna go over
them in a second so the work streams
were broken up into four key areas
building the foundation was a key part
of our project it allowed us to build
all the technical building blocks that
were needed before we migrated to GCP
second we migrated a pilot workload
this gave our teams the early access to
understand how a migration works and
then in parallel we also implemented a
data data center discovery tool that
analyzed all of our connections within
our data center so we can understand
what servers are communicating to others
and then our final final work stream was
our full Windows workload migration so
for this presentation we're actually
going to focus on the first and third
work streams so let's take a little
deeper into those foundational elements
I spoke about earlier so the foundation
really consisted of three parts cloud
governance understanding what governance
policies we needed to continue to do in
GCP while also building new policies
that were more cloud focused building a
landing zone so this is the the
technical building blocks I spoke about
earlier and all the pieces that were
part of that in order to migrate to TCP
and then we needed to bring in some new
tools and these tools were gonna help us
go along that journey so in the area of
cloud governance a couple questions were
asked early on such as which servers
could be migrated and how are we going
to manage them how are we going to
secure them and how are we going to
control cost so in the area of cloud
readiness we had to come up with a way
to identify how we had to come up with a
way to identify that our server
were ready so a couple examples
understanding how the license structure
of an application could translate from
on-premise to cloud understanding if the
applications support from the vendor
carried over the same level of support
that we had on-premise that that was a
key part
prior to migrating to TCP also
understanding the amount of
communication that servers were having
to each other on premise also was
important to understand if they were
cloud ready in the area of
infrastructure management what we had to
do there is understand that we were
going to continue to use some of our
on-premise applications in the areas of
patch management and load balancing and
monitoring and we identified this
because we wanted to ensure that we
didn't have a reduced functionality of
what we currently have but also we
wanted to also continue to leverage our
on-premise or our companies teams
expertise and the tools that they
already know now on the flip side to
that we are also continuing to
investigate more cloud focused solutions
to help us along our long-term journey
platform security so Colgate is a G
suite company so being able to integrate
with our current G suite implementation
we created custom custom groups that
made access to our Google platform for
our support teams quick and efficient
but then for our users we were able to
use the power of I M or Identity and
Access Management to give our users the
ability to be agile in the cloud but
also control some more sensitive areas
that we needed more control over and
then finally cost management we had to
come up with a way that once we migrated
to GCP how are we going to manage cost
so we did that in a couple different
ways by by exporting our billing
information from GCP to bigquery
we were able to leverage tools such as
data studio to build custom dashboards
to give us the needed visibility into
our costs for our projects
and then an area of control we used
billing alerts within the GCP console to
notify us that when projects reach a
certain overage in terms of their cost
structure so I want to go a little bit
deeper into the network architecture and
what we had to do to to be ready for a
cloud we knew early on that we had to
keep connectivity back to on-prem with
our with our cloud environment that
hybrid connectivity so and we also
wanted to make sure that we set up our
isolated networks in a way that we were
as secure as possible so originally we
set up we did this through multiple V
pcs for both are non prod and production
environments we also configured VPNs for
that hybrid connectivity to multiple
regions in the cloud that way we could
leverage that global GCP network and
then in a high in our higher traffic
areas we implemented interconnects to
ensure that that bandwidth has increased
now for our DCP communication we
implemented shared V pcs to enable our
projects within the same environment to
communicate to each other but in doing
so we also implemented micro
segmentation that way servers could
communicate to other servers only when
we allow it even if it's sitting on
within the same subnet that gave us the
highest level of security moving forward
so let's talk about some of the tools
that we're using to help us with our
migration journey so a division is an
agentless discovery tool that we
currently have deployed in our data
center it is helping us map our entire
server footprint of our data center and
it's doing that through a couple key
it's providing us a couple key things in
terms of technical details so as we as I
said server-to-server communication but
how often is that server communicating
to that other server right that could
help us identify some of our
talkers within our data center and as
they are communicating to each other
what kind of protocols are they using
TCP UDP is it inbound outbound traffic
what ports are they using right so
implementing something like micro
segmentation you need to have all that
information prior to migrating to GCP at
the end of it having that data center
footprint allowed us to create something
called migration move groups and what
that basically means is servers that
should move together get moved together
so for cloud security and compliance we
are leveraging security command center
along with for steady security and what
that's basically allowing us to do is
put in all the necessary rules in place
to make our GCP environment more secure
once those rules are in place we're not
only able to sniff out vulnerabilities
of areas in GCP but prevent them from
happening in the first place other areas
such as organizational policies that
allows us the highest level of controls
to be put in place that are then
hierarchy down to all of our service
projects so I want to talk a little bit
about server migration um
the tool that we are currently using is
called Bella strata so once your hybrid
connectivity is in place from your
on-prem environment to your data center
you basically have four major steps that
you need to do when using the Velo scrub
tool so step one would be to implement
your management management pieces of El
Estrada so what that is is an appliance
in your data center and that is directly
working with your VMware environment and
then you have your compute instances
running in the GCP side now these two
pieces of Bella strata are in constant
sync with each other they'll they allow
basically the entire migration process
that we're going to talk about on this
slide - to occur so once your management
pieces are in place we could begin -
migration so on Krim within your your V
Center VMware environment you're able to
exit
migration and what that's doing is it's
going to take the server configuration
that you have on Prem and replicate it
in the GCP environment but you do have
the option to change that configuration
based on different needs
maybe that server on Prem was sized at a
higher workload that it needed to be
within a short time 30 minutes or so the
GCP instances are accessible so that's a
key point here because you don't have to
have an excessive amount of downtime you
could turn over these instances to your
support teams or your application teams
to begin additional configuration or to
just begin testing of that application
in GCP in the meantime storage migration
migration begins
so the on-premise disks will then start
to begin the streaming of the move the
migrating of storage to new disks within
the GCP side now depending on the size
of those disks will correlate to the
length of that disk migration once a
storage migration is finished you're
basically ready to do your last step and
that step is called a detach and it's
attached is basically disconnecting your
on-premise environment from your DCP
environment in terms of El Estrada and
those disks that are now fully migrated
are now attached to those instances and
you're done that that in a nutshell is
your four steps on how to migrate your
on-premise servers to GCP I have a
couple slides here just to wrap up my
part of the presentation just want to
talk about some integration points to
consider when possibly migrating your
environment to DCP so in terms of
firewall management going to a DCP
environment or public cloud environment
you may want to consider a more granular
granular firewall management such as
micro segmentation but when doing so it
is critical to understand how your
on-premise environment is communicating
like I mentioned from our conversation
before about a division in terms of
patch management we might want to
consider a new patch management strategy
when going to the cloud this is a great
time to think about
that having a having a pre-migration a
detailed pre-migration plan where you
could identify some of the things that
might get missed during a migration is
key so yes we have our a division data
that's our technical data but being able
to supplement it with some something
that we do such as application
interviews where we speak to the
application owners and get some insights
that may be a tool can't give us so
being able to take that technical detail
and that app owner detail put it
together gives us a higher chance or
high confidence when migrating to GCP so
we don't miss something let's say an
application that might be leveraging a
load balancer IP address mapping so when
we are implementing hybrid environment
where you're connecting your GCP
environment to your on-premise
environment you want to make sure that
those subnets that you're provisioning
and GCP don't conflict with your subnets
that you already have within your data
center or globally for your company on
the application side you want to make
sure that you understand how your
applications are currently interfacing
on-premise that's going to be key to
understand how you're going to move not
just one application but many
applications at a time to keep those
move groups together you also want to
make sure that your external external
storage that your applications may use
stays intact
post migration and then having a very
good detailed cloud compatibility check
that's that cloud readiness could help
you avoid some potential issues in the
future let's talk about some post
migration benefits so a lot of benefits
that you hear usually come around a net
new environment so I mean someone is
building that new and these are all the
benefits that you get from running in
the cloud but a lot of those benefits
also correlate over to someone that's
migrating their servers to the cloud so
live migration all right being able to
reduce your potentially reduce your
maintenance windows by not having to
patch the physical hardware because the
live migration is
to the customer right sizing leveraging
Google's recommendation engine and
artificial intelligence to understand
when servers are underutilized or over
utilized and then provision the correct
sizing for those servers something even
as simple as hardware leases right when
migrating to the cloud you no longer
have to worry about the hardware leases
and managing those schedules fast their
provisioning not having to worry about
compassed the capacity planning which
every datacenter has to worry about and
and using the agility and the
scalability of the cloud platform to
provision faster and basically on-demand
and then finally reduce license
management so leveraging Google's images
such as Windows and sequel server you no
longer have to worry about those
licenses and managing those licenses
costs because they are built into the
into the build itself so in a nutshell
GCP is helping us as a company to become
more agile google's professional
services are continuing to help us grow
in that sector and then the tools that
were using are helping us to get to our
destination
[Music]